Hi, welcome back.
In this session, I want to move on and
talk a little more specifically about
risk, but with the easier of the two
financial asset classes, bonds.
The conventional wisdom is that bonds
are safe, but that turns out to be too
broad a brush. As we will see in this
session, you can have a bond that's
riskier than a than an average or a
low-risk stock, and we have to talk
about where that risk comes from.
So, to start the process, let's think
about the risk you face as an investor
in a bond. And this is the same risk you
face when you lend money to somebody
else.
Now, in a conventional bond, you are get
you are promised fixed payments in the
future, called coupons. At the end of
the life of the bond, and bonds usually
come with a finite life, you're given
the face value of the bond back, the
amount that was borrowed back. So, what
can go wrong? First, even though the
payments, the coupons are fixed and the
face value is fixed, if interest rates
change after you bought the bond, the
price of your bond will change. We talk
about that how much and which bonds are
more exposed, but there's price risk
coming from interest rate changing. So,
think of that as risk in interest rates,
and you're going to face that even if
you buy a bond issued by an entity that
has no default risk.
Now, if you add default risk to the mix,
that's a second risk you face. You
promise you've been promised fixed
payments, coupon payments, but those
promises might not be delivered. The
greater the risk that they will not be
delivered, the greater the default risk,
the greater the chance your returns will
be volatile as a consequence.
So, interest rate risk and default risk
drive the risk in a bond.
Let's start with interest rate risk.
The coupons and the face value of a bond
are set at the time of bond issuance.
So, when you buy a bond, you know there
are eight years of coupons, or 15 years
of coupons, or 30 years of coupons. You
know when the coupons will come, and you
know the face value of the bond, usually
$100, $1,000, whatever the set face
value is. Those are the promised cash
flows. Let's take the fortress out of
the out of the example for the moment.
At the time you buy the bond, let's say
interest rates were 3%.
And then a year later, or even 6 weeks
later, rates have risen to 4%. Your
coupons haven't changed, your face value
hasn't changed, but the price of the
bond is going to change because the
value of the bond will reflect the
present value of the coupons, the face
value at whatever the interest rates are
at the time you price the bond. So, if
interest rates go up, the price of the
bond will go down. If interest rates go
down, the price of the bond will go up.
By how much? Let's take a very simple
example.
Let's suppose you have a 4%
10-year coupon bond, and the face value
is a thousand.
So, you promise cash flows of 40 Let's
make the coupons annual simply for the
simple reason that, you know, it keeps
life a little simpler. It could be
semi-annual, nothing would change the
example.
It'll be a mild change in present value,
but let's act as if the coupons ran
them. $40 every year for the next 10
years. At the end of the 10th year, in
addition to the 40 in coupons, you get a
thousand in face value.
I've computed what the value of this
bond will be at rates ranging if
interest rates range from 2% all the way
up to 6%. Let's take the easiest
scenario. If the interest rates are 4%
and the bond is issued at the time
interest rates are 4%, the price of the
bond is going to be a thousand. It's
It's face value. If interest rates are
2% though, the bond price, because the
present value of the cash flows will be
higher, increases to 1,180. That's an
18% increase in bond price because rates
went down. Conversely, if rates rise to
6%, the price of this bond drops to
$853.
You can see that the price of the bond
will vary depending on what interest
rates are.
Just as an aside, in 2022,
a 10-year Treasury bond, So, no default
risk,
dropped in value by roughly 20%.
You know why? Cuz interest rates that
year went from a really low number, less
than 2%, to close to 4%.
When interest rates change, the price of
the bond will reflect it.
Now, if you look at this example, you
can already see what would drive that
percentage price change.
The higher the coupons the bond, the
less exposed it is to interest rate
changes. Why? Cuz the higher coupons
allow you to get the cash flows quicker.
If coupon rates drop, the coupon of the
bond becomes lower, the bond will become
more sensitive to interest rate changes.
At the limit, if you have a zero coupon
bond, where you have no coupons at all
and only the face value at the end of
the 10th year, the bond will be the most
sensitive. So, level of coupons matters.
The maturity of the bond matters. A
30-year bond, holding all else constant,
will be more sensitive to interest rate
changes than a 10-year bond. And a
10-year bond will be more sensitive than
a 5-year bond.
One way to capture both the coupon level
and the maturity is with a measure
called duration. What is a duration
measure? Duration, in many ways, is a
weighted average of when you get the
cash flows of the bond. So, as an
example, if you have a zero coupon bond,
it's a 10-year bond, the duration will
be 10 years cuz you get all your cash
flows at the end of 10 years. As you
start to add coupons on, the duration
for a 10-year bond will get less than 10
years and it'll drop the higher the
coupon on the bond.
You're saying, "That sounds abstract."
Let's take the 10-year bond, that in
fact the $40 4 4% 10-year bond that we
looked at earlier, and compute the
duration of the bond. This is the
simplest measure of duration. It's
called Macaulay duration. Here's what
I'm going to do. I'm going to first take
the present value of the bond of the
cash flow in each year. So, that's just
the present value of the cash flows to
to today. And then, I'm going to
multiply the present value by when I get
the cash flows. So, year one cash flow,
I'm going to multiply by one. Your two
cash flow, I'm going to multiply by two.
If you add up that last column, you get
7,714.
And you divide by the present value of
the bond, you get a duration of the bond
of 8.36 years. That incorporates both
the coupon and the maturity.
The higher the duration, the more
sensitive a bond is going to be to
interest rate changes.
Let's bring in default risk. When you
buy a bond, you're promised a coupon.
But that promise might not be delivered.
Your best case scenario with the bond is
you get the entire coupon.
You don't get You don't ever get more
than the coupon, no matter how well the
borrower is doing.
Your worst case scenarios, though, raise
the spectrum.
Your worst case scenario of all is you
receive none of the promised cash flows.
The potential or upside is limited. The
potential for downside is very large.
And I'm going to draw a proposition that
comes from that characteristic of bonds.
Because of the asymmetric risk that you
get lots more downside than upside risk
in a bond,
with bonds, we measure risk by looking
at only the downside risk or default
risk.
With equities, you see why we bring in
the upside. With bonds, it's mostly
downside risk.
So, what is it that drives default risk?
Three things.
First is the capacity to generate cash
flows from operations. A business that's
able to generate more cash flows from
operations will have less default risk
than one that generates less cash flows.
And the one that generates less cash
flows will have less default risk than
one that creates negative cash flows.
That's the first. The second is the
volatility in those cash flows. You take
two companies with exactly the same cash
flows. A company with stable cash flows
will have less default risk than one
with more unstable cash flows.
And to the extent that you have other
fixed commitments you have as a company,
lease commitments, contractual
commitments, that adds to your default
risk.
For as long as people have been trying
to lend money,
they've been trying to measure default
risk. And there are three broad measures
of default risk you will find. The first
is
a measure we run into as individuals or
as business, which is a credit risk
score.
Where people look at your age, your
income, your wealth,
and they assess a credit risk score.
Sometimes we think it's unfair, but as
lenders, you can see why a credit risk
score helps you determine what interest
rate to charge a borrower or whether to
lend them in the first place.
The second, and this is true for
corporations or publicly traded
companies, used to be primarily in the
US but now across the world, is a
rating. There are ratings agencies out
there, and we can debate how good or bad
they are, whether they're biased,
S&P, Moody's, Fitch, etc. And what these
ratings agencies do is they look at
publicly traded companies, they collect
information for these companies, mostly
public information, but sometimes
information that they get from the
managers,
and they assess a default risk for that
company with a rating. The ratings are,
you know, are not num- are are letters,
not numbers, and they range usually from
triple A, which is the safest you can be
as a company, down to D, where you're in
default.
There's a third way in which you measure
default, which is relatively recent.
Over the last 20 years, there's a market
that's developed called the credit
default swap market. What does it allow
you to do?
If you're somebody who's bought a bond
and you're worried about default risk,
it allows you to buy insurance against
default risk in the form of a CDS
spread.
What is that spread? If that spread is 1
and 1/2% and you bought this on a bond
where you collected 6% coupon or an
interest rate,
you pay 1 and 1/2% every year to
insurance yourself against default.
You can see what this gives you, right?
It gives you a market set number for
that default spread given your default
risk. Credit risk scores, bond ratings,
default swaps.
Now, in this graph, there are two things
I try to illustrate. First is that the
ratings agencies for the most part get
it right, right? So, if you go from AAA
down to D, and these are both Moody's
and S&P's, you can see that the default
spread widens. So, for the most part,
much as we abuse ratings agencies, they
get the rating right.
The other thing to note in this graph is
how default spreads vary over time.
Let's take a triple B rated company that
remained triple B between 2021 and 2025.
In 2021, the default spread for that
company was 1.71%.
In 2023, the default spread had jumped
to 20 at 2%. And in 2025, the start, it
had dropped back to 1.2%. At the risk of
stating the obvious, default spreads can
vary across time as the economy shifts
as you go from more scary times to
better times in the economy.
Now, what do ratings agencies look at to
come up with their assessments of
ratings? Much as we like to attribute
all the special information they have,
for the most part, ratings are based on
information that's publicly available.
In fact, they're based primarily on
ratios you can compute for companies.
The The ratio that I find most useful in
explaining difference across ratings is
called the interest coverage ratio. You
take the operating income and divide by
interest expense. The higher that
number, notice, as you look across the
top line, the higher the rating of the
company.
So, rated companies, if you're trying to
explain ratings, look at the numbers
first. The answer usually lies there.
Now, there are companies out there that
are not rated, smaller companies in the
US, a lot of non-US companies.
And for those companies, you can assess
default risk by coming up with your own
version of rating, acting like a ratings
agency. Like, let's take a simplistic
version
of how the ratings agency attaches a
rating. Say you compute an interest
coverage ratio. You should be able to do
that for any company anywhere in the
world. You take operating income
earnings before interest and taxes and
divide by interest expense.
If you have a company with 3.5 billion
in operating in earnings before interest
and taxes and interest expense of 700
million, your interest coverage ratio is
five. So, what do I do with that?
I will look up table where based on
rated companies will tell me what your
interest coverage ratio is, I can tell
you what kind of rating you should have.
So, the company you're looking at is a
smaller company with an interest
coverage ratio of five, their rating
should be single A at least the time
this table was put together. The default
spread should be roughly 1%.
So, whether it's with actual ratings,
synthetic ratings, credit driven default
spreads, or credit scores,
you should be able to assess the default
risk in a borrower and from that come up
with a spread that goes with it.
So, here are the here's the bottom line
with when it comes to risk in bonds.
While we generally describe bonds as
safe, there's a huge continuum of risk
in bonds and they can be
they can vary based on both the maturity
and the coupon of the bond as well as
the default risk in the bond.
So, if you have a bond with no default
risk,
that the bond can still be risky to a
short-term investor because the price of
the bond can change as interest rates
change as well.
So, when you walk into a bond
investment, it's good to be aware of
both interest rate risk
and default risk and factor them into
your decision making.
I hope you found the session useful.
And in the next session, we'll move on
to looking at risk from an equity
investor's perspective.